hey guys it's max we just got in
v-moda's brand new m200 inc
headphones and we're gonna be comparing
them to the airpods max and we're gonna
see
does apple finally have some serious
competition we're not only gonna compare
the sound quality in multiple
genres we're going to compare the active
noise cancellation their transparency
modes
the microphones build quality value and
much more
let's go ahead and get this open these
are my first v-moda
headphones and i know they're very
popular they have a great reputation
and these are actually their very first
active noise cancellation headphones
right in the box we have
this nice case with a zipper not a
little magnetic flap
so let's set this aside and it's kind of
a mix between a hard shell case and a
little bit soft
and bam there are the headphones now if
you want to compare to apple's case
this rubbery thing i don't want to talk
about that too much this is the kind of
case that i would have wanted with the
airpods max
so let's go ahead and pull these out wow
all right i love that they flip
in they stay much more compact let's pop
these open
i'm going to be careful so i don't break
them oh no
i don't want to do it that way there we
go
all right so the headband is pretty
springy
as far as build quality is a lot of
aluminum here you look at the arms
you look at these little shields that
you can't actually replace and customize
we do have a good amount of plastic up
over here and it doesn't feel
cheap but it also doesn't feel premium
at least for this price tag and i do
have both of these listed
down below and i think the airpods max
are finally in stock now
and then we have this little cable that
connects uh both
together we have this hinge right here
that adds a little bit extra pressure
against your head
the headband material is like this uh
leathery material and it actually
doesn't feel
as soft as i expected there's not too
much give here
and as far as adjustability we have a
good range here
and it is using the standard kind of
click method to adjust and lock it in
and the ear pads are quite soft there's
not a lot of room
for movement but they are very soft and
we have this unique kind of
hexagonal shape that v-moda typically
uses
let's grab the airpods max and see how
they compare
right away you could tell they are
heavier in the hand we have 385 grams
compared to 310
but the materials do feel nicer we have
all aluminum here we have stainless
steel
and this kind of a soft rubberized
finish
and the headband as you guys might see
my finger just
just pushes up against it you have so
much room and flexibility here
and as far as the ear cups that you have
a little bit more travel
and they're also very soft probably
about the same level of softness now one
thing about the airpods max is
you can pop these covers off they are
expensive but you can buy different
colors and replace them
so that is really nice and it looks like
the v-moda's also have magnetic ear cups
i had no idea that is very cool since
you can easily and quickly
swap them out and replace them now
before i put these on and test out
comfort
i want to mention that of course the
v-modas use usb type-c
to charge but along with that they give
you an airplane adapter
and they give you a cable if you want to
use it wired whereas
apple does not apple charges you extra
all right let's put on the earpods max
of course i have used these
a ton now i one day i think i was almost
12 hours of wearing them
these are super comfortable even though
they are very heavy they do have a bit
of pressure around your ears
but as far as the headband they don't
have pressure build up like most
headphones do
which is why i love the comfort of these
let's go ahead and take these off and
let's
give the v-modas a go so this is the
right hand right here
all right okay very interesting
first off okay i'm not gonna talk about
the noise cancellation
but um i do feel the headband more so i
feel the ear cups a lot less
but the ear cups aren't as deep as the
airpods max these are
super deep so my ears actually don't
touch the insides whereas here they do
touch
but it does still feel comfortable feels
fairly lightweight on my head
the headband is more comfortable than i
expected now of course this is just my
first impressions we will be doing a
review
and in that review we can talk about
long-term comfort after i've worn them
for
hours and hours so that's not bad now
the v-modas do have buttons
up here at the top somewhere all right
there there they are so there's three
buttons
not so you can control your volume and
then we have an active noise
cancellation button
down below now the bottom button feels
quite nice it's fairly clicky but these
top buttons
they feel very mushy for some reason
not springy at all now the airpods max
they're very simple as far as controls
we have our little button right here to
toggle between your active noise
cancellation
modes and then you have the little dial
the crown so you can adjust your volume
skip tracks things like that so the
controls wise feel like these are a
little bit more simple and they're very
easy to find now let me quickly show you
guys the app it is
very very basic but it does have an app
where the airpods max
does not include one and then here we
can go into the sound settings adjust
our noise cancellation we do have an
equalizer which is great
and then the other option is auto off so
it looks like by default
um is not enabled so you can't switch it
to 30 minutes or three hours and of
course you can just shut it off yourself
whereas with the airpods max
you don't have a power on or off button
it's automatic and you have to wait for
it to go into low power mode
and shut off now as far as battery life
both these are rated for 20 hours so
they're rated identical
therapeuts max get a little bit more
than that 24 to 25 in real world use
but of course you get some drain if you
leave them for
a few days without that power button and
now let's compare the active noise
cancellation i'm going to start out with
the off mode where it's just testing out
kind of the seal and how well they block
out noise by themselves so i have the
airpods max set to off
and it does block out quite a bit i do
almost have some like self
noise or just i don't know a little bit
of
weirdness here but it blocks out a lot
surprisingly
and let's try the v-modas
all right that's actually a pretty good
amount of blockage a little bit less
than the airpods max i hear that vent
above me a little bit more so than with
the airpods max
let's go ahead and turn on the active
noise cancellation
all right wow okay this is interesting
depending on the seal it changes a
little bit so all right that's better
it got rid of all the low the low
frequency sounds whoa my voice sounds
kind of weird though
almost like a rumbling that's added to
my voice i haven't heard that from other
active noise cancellation headphones
i hear a little bit of the highs but wow
that is better than i expected wow
okay let's try out the airpods max
all right and silence
all the lows are also are also gone
the highs are pretty much gone too and
my voice doesn't have any of that
digital kind of weirdness so let me go
back and forth between these two
yep so these are a little bit worse than
the airpods max the lows are fantastic
and i presume if you're in an airplane
these are going to do a great job but
the highs is where you get a little bit
more coming through and maybe that's
just because the seal isn't as good
and then i just feel the the weirdness
in my voice when i'm talking i don't
know how much that matters to you guys
maybe they can fix that with firmware
but it just sounds a little bit weird
now one cool feature of these v-modas is
the ability to put your hand
over the ear cup like this and then
about a second later it goes into your
ambient
ambient mode or your talking mode so you
can hear somebody
and as soon as you put your hand away it
goes back into active noise cancellation
now i wish that the airpods max had that
be very convenient so you have to keep
toggling on and off uh but oddly enough
the v-moda's don't have an ambient mode
that you can leave
on all the time that is the feature that
you use
whereas with the airpods max you have
apple's transparency mode you could
toggle
and it is absolutely incredible the best
out of any headphones that i have heard
and
you know all of the reviewers say the
same thing it sounds like you literally
don't have anything on not digital
or artifact anything like that and in
this mode
i hear you know just like in real life
whereas the v-modas when you put your
hand over the sides it still sounds a
bit digital
and now let's compare the sound quality
i have three different tracks
that are no copyright so you guys can
listen along i'll keep it short and then
i'll give you guys my
kind of opinions and the differences
that i hear so let's go ahead
and take a listen
[Music]
all right guys well that was
very interesting i have two things that
i have to mention
first off uh we had some real weirdness
when i started listening to the track or
when those really deep
the deep bass kind of kicked in i don't
know did you hear anything vadim
yeah it was more sound leakage on the uh
v mode
a lot more sound leakage on the v-moda's
okay but you didn't hear any crunchiness
uh i heard something weird in the mids
yeah i actually had to turn it down
because
i was having almost like a distortion
like when you push your sub too far
um it was very weird i haven't heard
that from other headphones at least in
this price range
so i clicked it down by one or two
clicks
and that got rid of that it was still
really loud very loud
bass sound is great i think this is
probably the best aspect of these
headphones so far
is sound quality uh everything else
doesn't really match up to headphones
that cost this much but the sound there
was good of course the airpods max they
made me really happy
that's why i couldn't return them even
though i wanted to the sound quality is
just
awesome okay but with that i don't know
if i can call a winner yet
let's go ahead and take a listen to our
next song which is going to be more of a
modern classical instrumental track
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right once again very
interesting now i have to say
these definitely sound better than the
sony's the xm4s
then the bose as far as sound quality
v-moda they did a great job now this
actually with the ink versions they are
40 mil drivers instead of 50s
just like the airpods max are 40mm
drivers so the drivers went down but
still has really deep
rich bass frequencies are kind of a
little bit higher a little bit sharper
than the airpods max
they sound fantastic now soundstage-wise
which this
track is excellent for the airpods max
are definitely wider that's where i
showed like i felt in that song that is
this this far away from me for close
backs these are great for our sound
stage these are still good
just not as good now there's one part of
the song where
a lot of headphones can distort at max
volume and i had this
turned down just a little bit not maxed
out it was still
plenty loud and i had to knock it down
one more bar because it did distort once
again just like in that first track i
don't know if they can fix that in
software it can go to the eq
and make sure that doesn't happen but
that part of it's a bummer but overall
sound quality
both are very very good the sound
signature is a little bit different
but the sound stage is better on the
airpods max and now
let's go ahead and do the most difficult
test
which is rock music where we have a ton
of different instruments ton of
different sounds and vocals in there
it's going to get interesting
[Music]
till the day that we dream
okay okay well they sound good for rock
music
uh at first the vocals were a little bit
too high there they're too loud compared
to the rest of the track
um then i went into the app because we
do have an equalizer
i hit the rock button and bam right
there
it fixed that and it sounded fantastic
now
uh with the airpods max i actually try
to turn them up a little bit more
uh because i want it to be a little bit
louder which is not good for your ears
at all you shouldn't be doing that but i
love loud music
and with the v-modas they get louder and
they sounded fantastic i didn't hear any
distortion
um i do wish the mids are maybe a little
bit more rich um so overall i'll say the
airplanes max do have better sound
quality a better
balance and the reason why they weren't
that loud in here is because they
tune themselves all the time they have
an inward facing microphone
so they will not distort on you at all
whereas with these
i had to turn them down to stop them
from distorting so
that could be fixed in the future but
overall as far as sound quality i am
very impressed
with these headphones and now for the
final test microphone
quality let's go ahead and compare them
this is the microphone quality
of the v-moda m200 inks
built-in microphones and this is the
microphone quality of apple's
airpods max built in microphones so go
ahead let me know
down below which one sounds better and
now for the verdict which one of these
headphones should you spend your hard
earned money on apple's airpod max
or the v-moda m200 inks
now personally i have to say that i
would have a hard time spending 500
on these the sound quality is good
the active noise cancellation has a
little bit issues which could be ironed
out
the voice control feature that is cool
uh but
there's no always on ambient mode just
yet and what really kind of bugs me the
most is just the build quality
for this amount of money you take a look
at the bose 700s
those you can buy for 329 right now they
are definitely better built
the plastic feels a lot better um and i
don't know it's just
that's kind of tough to drop that much
money on something like this whereas
with airpods max
we know that most likely microphones are
better
the comfort most likely is better as
well sound quality you don't get any of
that distortion the active noise
cancellation mode is
awesome and the build quality is amazing
and then if you're an ios user or you
have a mac
you have the extra features built in
which is great
but you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below
is there something that you really love
about these that would make it worth it
or maybe you've owned other v-modas and
just want active noise cancellation and
wireless
headphones that are the same i want to
hear your guys's thoughts i have links
to both down below
go ahead and click that circle above to
subscribe and help us reach our goal of
600 000
subscribers if you want to see some more
airpods max videos we have some
right over there this one max and i will
see you in the next video